this is inherently just a guessing game
in that we both know the region we just
have no clue which one no it's what it
is so we just got to get a multiple
choice right now yeah okay but let's get
guess we can randomly land on it okay
urdu
okay and i was going to go with
bangalore
okay it's near neither of those just
keep going hindi
sri lankan
so sri lanka has two official languages
it is one of them do you know what they
are
sri lankan and more dark
hey man listen listen let me give a
shout out to my sri lankan people i i
got a lot of love for y'all
i mean you're not wrong no he's not hey
man hey listen sri lankans are the
[ __ ] of that area and shout outs to
them okay no they know they know the
struggle they know
i used to go to the school um
and uh
she was dark as hell and i used to love
it i used to be like amy you know you're
my favorite south asian
[Laughter]
because all the indians you know they
pride themselves off sometimes i'm being
light-skinned yeah where the sri lankans
are always kind of seen as the more
darker folks yeah um
i think i think it looks weird
yeah yeah shout out to them my a lot of
sri lankans in my high school so my best
friend's going yeah
the darkest dude in the world i know was
sri lankan yeah yeah yeah there's just
something funny about weird [ __ ]
i have her here's the thing
but i get it you wanna know why i get it
this is why i i get it because when i go
to africa or go to canyon i see dark
[ __ ] you know bald head cool yeah but
when i see ned flanders with like the
complexion of a kenyan it looks darker
for some reason because the the
juxtaposition between the [ __ ]
mushroom cut and the dark hair is crazy
crazy and sri lanka's got crazy looking
hair so shout out to them i get it i get
it
yeah if you see somebody from like black
panther looking dark like you don't even
really take it in because they fall yeah
i'm saying like yeah girl go do your
thing but you see that hair you're like
damn okay
you came off the set of the simpsons was
wrong bro
i just want to clarify i don't rank my
friends from dark delight i just happen
to notice this one in particular all
seeing your colorist ways